tonight one of the most iconic spots in
las vegas becomes more than a tourist
trap alex
it's a coronavirus vaccine clinic yeah
we're talking about the welcome to
fabulous las vegas sign hector mejia is
there live now with details about the
event tonight hey hector good morning
hey there good morning the sign has been
in movies tv shows and millions of
photos right now we actually have a mini
photo session going on underneath the
welcome to las vegas sign
and tonight it will play host to the
valley's next vaccination effort
clark county immunized nevada and toro
university teamed up for tonight's
vaccine event
they'll have the pfizer vaccine as well
as the johnson and johnson
the pfizer vaccine was recently approved
for anyone 12 and over
vegas fashion there will be a
photographer on hand to snap
professional pictures of everyone who
gets vaccinated
former fda commissioner dr scott godley
says more people need to keep rolling up
their sleeves
we're finding out now that the vaccines
make it highly unlikely you'll even
spread the virus
if you're fully vaccinated with one of
the available vaccines you're going to
not only be much less likely to get
infected either symptomatic or
asymptomatic infection
but if you do get infected if you are
vaccinated and you become
asymptomatically infected you're far
less likely to transmit the infection
we've been telling you about creative
vaccine events happening only here in
town this past
friday the larry flint hustler club gave
shots to around 100 people and they
handed out what they called
a package that was worth thousands of
dollars five thousand dollars in fact
and again
the pop-up clinic here underneath the
welcome to las vegas sign the welcome to
fabulous las vegas sign is at 7 p.m
underneath the sign and if you are
coming down here they encourage people
to go ahead and park at harley-davidson
just across the street
parking here at this side is pretty
limited so you can park across the
street and also they will have some food
trucks in case you get hungry
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now